you get given two conditions namely
excuse me the K is some real number key
that I'm multiplying my eye and then
you've got all of this garbage in here
that multiplies apparently to a purely
imaginary number and then this is what
they want you to show something to do to
to modulite okay now how would you even
begin such a question in I've Ella you
know just in Cartesian form or in
metallic form right now you can do them
you can solve any question in any way
you like but representation it's
different representations make different
things fall upon easily okay so here's
where we're gonna begin let's try this
on the diagram to be moving okay so I
know the K is real number and say one
man I said Tuesday 1 plus said - I know
what they represent they represent
diagonals in a parallelogram
okay so let's draw this thing I'm not
gonna leave behind all the cool stuff I
know about moduli and arguments okay
there's still gonna be useful to me but
now that I think about this whole
geometric plane there's parallelograms
and other kinds of shapes in here that I
know how they behave I could take
advantage of that so what right this is
what I know they give this to me as I am
I'm just statement that is true so I'm
gonna use that as much starting point
I've got did one take away there - did
one plus is there - okay okay now just
see through how much stuff there is for
a second and recognize that look when
you had - when you add two complex
numbers what kind of number do you get
out the other end another complex number
right if you subtract two complex
numbers what kind of number do you get
out the end it's up another complex
number and then when you take those two
complex numbers and divide the question
of two complex numbers still complex
number okay so this awful mess is a
complex number that's a complex number
so therefore both of these things have
an argument do you agree with that
because all complex numbers have an
octave so I'm gonna say the argument of
this complex number which admittedly
looks messy
should be the same as the argument of
this comment sub up because the equation
says they're the same complex not long
so they must have the same argument
that's good
okay now have a look at this right tell
me what you remember about what happens
when you take complex numbers divide
them and therefore what that means about
their arguments okay maybe I'll remind
you for instance a student easy case if
you take two complex numbers that we
multiply what happens to their arguments
in the new combined complex the bond
they've been added haven't they exam
plus odd Omega right so that's what
happens in more vacation what happens
with subtraction
sorry submission reason I came to the
answer you're walking okay so therefore
I've got this angle up top right and I'm
taking away this angle argument down the
bottom okay so far so good
what's the argument of K I'm recognizing
that K is any real number you're like
any real number ah yeah very good so if
I say that K is just a real number then
K itself is on the real axis you agree
somewhere I don't know how far or which
side the real axis but I know it's on
there once I do ki I know it's the
opposite it's on the imaginary axis and
an or which is which side but it's on
there right so therefore I know it's
argument has to be some multiple of what
now really you've only got two options
don't you I could think about it as like
biology 3.25 bah-bah-bah
or I could just think about the
principle argument there's only two
options out there there's the top one
which is peyote and then there's the
bottom one which is negative points okay
and the K doesn't make a difference
doesn't make it a soothing argument
right it makes it a sin modulus but the
argument doesn't care it's just talking
about like which way around your face
all right now hold on a second remember
this is just an angle and this is just
some other angle right so if I say okay
I have two angles let's just call them
alpha and me up right and when you
subtract them you get like say PI on to
what does that mean about the two angles
don't forget I could have made it as
well but it's the safety right what I
mean is that they're 90 degrees PI o 2
radians apart from each other
for instance one might be one might be
okay let's just let's just going up
we're just going degrees for a second
just to be nice t1 could be 90 and one
could be the outside one could be 120
and one could be thirty right or maybe
one could be a hundred and ten and one
could be twenty they off by 90 degrees
okay so what does that mean about these
two they're at right angles to each
other right they're 90 degrees pilots
Iranians off from one another but I know
where these guys are what are these two
guys the diagonals of my parallelogram
which apparently according to this are
my angles the diagonals of my
parallelogram are right angles are what
kind of a parallelogram has diagonals at
right angles are rhombus wellness a
Clank does have diagonals right angles
but a kite is not a parallelogram and
that's where I began
apparently
yeah so I'm parallelogram plus
perpendicular okay well a square is a
kind of rhombus so that's okay
so this says can we just finish this on
yet therefore write the diagonals excuse
me this parallelogram updated Oh a CB or
AC B are perpendicular okay
if the danglers replica and I already
know it's parallelogram it must be
enormous
it might even be a square but I don't
need to know that therefore o ACB is a
rhombus and I almost don't need to say
anything else do i what am I trying to
proving it I'm trying to prove that
these two things there what is there to
this guy and this guy have the same
light college by definition or on the
Stars I guess I would say Oh a equals B
because I'm talking about legs all sides
rhombus
and oh and Obi represents respectively
the victors of z1 and z2 so their
magnitudes unsafe because I was talking
about lights okay their computation
right we'll just use logic and what we
know about the fabric of context of is
an edge geometry question yes that's a
great question that's a great question
okay the brilliant thing about this is
that okay that's it one - ed - okay now
this is the free vector right this is
the free mcduck so where is the position
vector of Z what might have said - and
the answer is it's down here right all
the venues
so therefore the ankle the argument I'm
talking about is right there yeah now
where is a wizard one what said - well I
already have its argument it's here
right but if these guys aren't right
angles to each other then those two are
right angles to each other because look
I have ultimate angles do you see them -
no worries great question okay so this
is what starts you off in the exercise
1.3 there's more to say about the
geometry this is just like touching and
scraping the surface okay but can you
see how it's like well with this whole
new world complex numbers are the bridge
between algebra is all algebra stuff
trigonometry is a particular kind of a
drug right house right geometry right
like all for a very long time people
could not bring these together complex
numbers just do it effortlessly by their
very nature
okay it's hard to wrap your head around
because it's trying to pull together all
these strands yeah but you take your
time to the questions together